bartlett we're a collaborative research
institute in uh theoretical computer
science
but with a uh outward-facing view
it's computer science and other areas of
of science and
and technology and society
particularly you know where a
computational perspective is
is important we run
um two
main programs each semester
uh that bring long-term visitors here
and also these shorter
uh
smaller often more speculative um uh
summer clusters you know aimed at i
guess
uh perhaps less established topics that
we can organize more quickly um we're
very happy to be hosting this cluster on
ai and humanity
over this summer and welcome to the
workshop for this cluster
first of all a big thank you to the
organizers
uh helen nissenbaum thomas crandall
gilbert jake golden fine colonel parsley
and jian yang
thanks to those folks
[Music]
great schedule for this week i'll hand
over to helen to introduce the workshop
in a moment
just a few words on logistics so
you
should have discovered the
food and coffee
that's there for breaks for lunches
you're on your own um through the
through the three days this week
masking
masks indoors are strongly recommended
um uh
you know outdoors of course you're
you're welcome to wear a mask um we ask
you not to bring food and drinks in
inside into the into the auditorium
please enjoy those outside water is fine
um at lunch time if you need to leave
some belongings here in the in the
building there are lockers on the far
side
that work with a pin code so you're
welcome to uh
welcome to make use of those
uh you should have all discovered wi-fi
our videographer is omid farr in the
booth here uh he's going to help
speakers hook up computers and
microphones um because of course
everything is uh streamed and we've got
you know video available on youtube and
the website um
and also a big thank you to uh elizabeth
yuen our events coordinator at the back
here uh for all the local arrangements
all right so uh enjoy the the three days
of the workshop looking forward to it
um so let me i'm helene simbon and let
me take the opportunity to thank peter
for
somehow within the definition of the
simon's institute
managing to squeeze us in
because this has been very generative so
far
so thanks peter thank you so much
elizabeth and just generally to the
simon staff who are
fantastic and have been incredibly
helpful
so
um
a few other things
you heard who the co-organizers are
we've been meeting
over the course of
how long
since
january
across
crazy time zones
and
just
trying to formulate
the conception behind
both the cluster and also the workshop
if you've gone to the website you've
seen
this notion of air and humanity
entering through this
issue of human centered ai
which is i think one of the latest don't
worry ais great
phrases
and
um
our
thought is
what is the human
part of this diet because a lot of
attention has been grabbed by the ai
part of this diet but how does what
assumptions
are built into ai about the humans
and
is that good for humanity
and is it good for societal institutions
is it good for our values and so forth
so
that's the perspective we wanted to take
just for this cluster
and um
even with well-meant technologies like
assistive robots
smart devices
decision assistants
we keep pushing at this question what
are the humans that are modeled or
represented or embodied in those systems
and um
are they beneficial
for humanity again for society for
values
for institutions and so forth
so i should mention that
using this as the theme people were
identified as
doing work relevant
and
particularly for this workshop we wanted
to include
participant speakers who could bring
insight to these kinds of questions
and
so the next thank you is for everyone
who's sitting in this room everyone
who's agreed to give a talk because this
isn't your standard disciplinary
workshop and we have at least
nine or ten disciplines
represented in the group depending on
how you count and it's not always
easy to know because many of us are
cross-disciplinary
cross-disciplinary
i am officially a philosopher but i've
absorbed all sorts of other disciplines
because this problem this question
isn't in my view something that can be
solved
by drawing on the resource the
intellectual resources of only
one discipline all right so i'm not
going to steal too much more time away
from the panel and just to let you know
we've built in a very nice long lunch
so that if we do need to push a little
bit and we're not going to let people
uh go
much over time i i have this bell
thank you peter but no i mean you know
i'll just be a little bit
uh bossy in making sure that we stay on
time each speaker will have
approximately
no more than 15 minutes
and then we will
clamp together the discussion
um which i'll moderate
just uh one more
house did i forget anything
partners
jake
okay
um about the masking we
i think i'm gonna go around
peter can we open
the exterior door
just to you know maybe get a bit of
airflow into the room
i think um often the rule can be that
the speaker can take his or her mask off
but we request that others
uh use masks but we will try and get
some airflow into the room
all right
so our three speakers
are tom gilbert who i'm
thrilled to have as a postdoc
at cornell tech at the digital life
initiative
gian yang who
will be second
and um
bernard keenan who joins us from burbank
thank you i'm pleased to see you
from burbank college so let me welcome
you in hand
thanks helen
hey mike
okay
um
yeah so greetings everyone uh it's an
honor to be here i should say
technically back here since um
i was affiliated with the simon's
institute in fall 2020 on a a program
for the semester called theory of
reinforcement learning
um
and actually many of the ideas in this
talk uh were born in that that convening
uh originally so that's
that's also to say again like thanks to
peter uh for helping with that previous
program
and for providing me the space to
develop a lot of the uh
the the perspective i'll briefly kind of
outline in this talk
so this is based on one of the
chapters my phd thesis it's now been
subsequently published
and um
it's it's really a kind of window into
what i was doing for a lot of my phd
which was here at berkeley um and i was
i was based primarily at um
a lab called the center for human
compatible ai or chai uh for short as we
affectionately called it
and it was it was a lab that was
concentrating on what was known as what
is known uh as a problem called ai
safety a research
field called ai safety and the goal of
ai safety is basically to
solve
the problem of making ai beneficial
by building what they call and you can
check the website
for the language on this but what they
call provably beneficial systems
where provably beneficial was a term
that was often used
in talks on the website and in various
documents but was was nev in my view was
never actually interrogated or explored
um and i i joined chai self-consciously
as a humanist
uh because i was interested in
uh this problem of defining what
beneficial ai might mean or just what
beneficial might mean itself
especially in relationship with
uh another emerging research field which
i think many of you are familiar with uh
which
you know often goes by this kind of
fairness accountability transparency
lens on ai systems i'll just sort of
more broadly refer to it here is the
politics of refusal where
uh the question of how you you might
build beneficial ai is rooted not in
terms of some abstract
formal model
that is accurate with respect to what
it's trying to model about people or
institutions or choices people make but
rather
in the endorsement or the affirmation of
affected communities
basically unless you have some kind of
positive signal
so to speak from the people most
affected by what you're building
endorsing what you're doing as a
designer
unless you have that then what you're
doing is problematic regardless of bias
regardless of
the date on which was trained anything
like that and i came into to try because
i was interested in the tension between
these two perspectives on this problem
and i i got really interested in
um not so much sort of speaking up as a
humanist to critique which i was doing
externally but rather to try a version
of what i i came to really own as a form
of imminent critique
uh which those of you who are familiar
with critical theory or the marxist
tradition uh you know that imminent
critique is basically a way of trying to
bore into a paradigm from within
uh to uncover within it contradictions
uh that are not resolvable within that
paradigm as a basis for moving from
moving forward and for me that was sort
of a very interesting question of
um what is an imminent critique of ai
what would that mean today uh to to to
become a computer scientist um and to
uh have a profound skepticism in this
paradigm even as i became very
intricately involved in it uh and that
was really the root of of this work for
me so i started learning
uh which i was trying to do and that a
lot of a lot of the um
the technical agenda that they were
pursuing that a safety was pursuing that
they're still pursuing i should say
um is conceptually rooted in a paradigm
that i think was was well expressed by
william mccaskill
he's more often no he's a philosopher
he's more often known as one of the
founders of effective altruism it's a
very prominent kind of ethics movement
on the global scale which i'm happy to
speak a little bit more about during the
q a or the panel if we want um but
mccaskill's view is that basically uh
the way we should go about solving
trolley problems
uh which is to say the kinds of moral
dilemmas that you can formally model uh
and conceivably resolve through some
kind of like revealed or expressed
preference
from whoever you're asking about this
moral dilemma the dilemma of who you
should kill in the case of a trolley
problem
is what he calls metanormativism which
is basically a recourse to more data in
other words well if we knew more about
what is at stake in that dilemma if we
knew more about
the five people that the trolley might
hit or if the one person i might save is
my mother or my aunt or my best friend
or has terminal cancer or something like
that if we dissolve that abstraction by
collecting more information from the
world we can basically use bayesian
inference to solve moral dilemmas that's
basically the idea here that there's
some kind of uncertainty over our
assumptions that we can minimize reduce
the bias and in so doing
um
solve a lot of the ethical and moral
quandaries that that ai is encumbered
with uh when we think about the bias or
the uh the inaccuracy of these systems
being built so
the
the resulting problem stops being a
moral dilemma and turns more into a kind
of practical dilemma of how do we get
how do we leverage enough data how do we
get enough information from the world
from people from institutions
so that uh the assumptions by which our
systems are built are more robustly more
accurately
uh
modeled and incorporated you basically
reduce any kind of like fundamental
tension
uh between moral priorities into a
question of of epistemic inference
and this is a very influential position
i was kind of interested by how
influential it was and how
uninterrogated this was
by many of the people i was actively
collaborating with uh and working with
and you know i'll just i don't want to
dwell on this because i think i'm
speaking to an audience that is maybe
not so sympathetic to this way of
thinking so i'll just sort of briefly
say
um that i was interested in this puzzle
of like well where is the the designer
where is the ai designer putting
themselves in the kind of epistemic
hierarchy that defines whatever the the
system is that they're building if you
deploy
a classifier uh uh for for computer
vision for for you know medical imaging
let's say in a hospital um there's a
vast in largely informal institutionally
backed up division of labor uh comprised
of just you know some forms of expertise
i put on the slide of whose judgment
whose discretion goes into its use its
application what cases is appropriate or
inappropriate for what ratio of false
positives or false negatives are
acceptable it's a it's a vast normative
landscape that you you just can't
resolve by just getting more data
because
that implies some vantage point some
perspective
on the domain that is
not neutral because you're situated in
that domain when you're looking at it
when you're building a system like this
and so i sat with this tension for years
because i knew and still believe
that these assumptions and these ideas
are going to inform what for the next
several decades will define
uh public policy for ai and economic
policy for ai that i think in 20 30
years a lot of the ideas behind ai
safety are going to inform
how the federal reserve works in in 30
or 40 years how we define economic
policy for the remainder of the 21st
century that basically if you think for
the historical parallel here is like the
chicago school of economics in the 50s
or 60s right not really taken seriously
by many other people scene actually is
quite outlandish milton friedman was not
taken seriously in his early career
right up until he was and i was
interested to be on the ground floor of
a place like that i wanted to ask myself
what can i say to these people
about what they're doing how can i how
can i help them and help myself
even make sense of these problems in a
way that uh
actually could be conducive to the ai
paradigm whatever that means
uh how do we move maybe past or
problematize the politics of refusal how
do we enrich it how do we make it
something that can be grocked by
mainstream computer scientists and ai
theorists and so for me
i became much more comfortable with this
language of what what me and some of my
collaborators came to call normative
indeterminacy
uh rather than just uncertainty
uh which i'll just say for the purpose
of this talk had two precepts basically
that social norms
uh are not simply kind of discoverable
through data or encodable
uh in terms of you know your your python
script or your api or whatever it is but
they're also like you're enacting them
by the conditions under which you are
developing these tools
this is an insight that of course goes
back to like second order cybernetics
the idea that the designer of the system
is also somehow implicated in the
feedback the system is taking in or
generating
um and i i basically just you know
refurbished those arguments but tried to
make it copacetic to
uh the style of thinking the patterns
the dispositions of work
uh that were now being pursued you know
in the lab i was a member of and then
secondly um the second kind of point
here is that developing what whatever
safe ai means
uh is is really going to amount among
other things to developing practices
uh that affirm distinct value
commitments that how you comport
yourself as a designer
uh how you professionally determine your
relationship with the system you're
building and the people affected by the
system you're building and how you
justify that relationship
is really at the core of what safety
means
that safety is not just something you
can put in a model or the system you're
building it's something you have to
inhabit
uh in as a designer
and so analytically what that then led
me to was thinking about
going back
thousands of years how have philosophers
tried to make sense of this problem of
indeterminacy so in the paper that this
talk is based on we go into this in more
detail i can say a bit more during the
panel but basically there's this problem
of vagueness that is really central to
the western philosophical tradition
hobbes basically took vagueness as the
jumping off point for the relations of
sovereignty
and vagueness broadly refers to this
problem of the fundamental lack of
clarity and the concepts that we use to
describe ourselves our relationship with
the world how we make sense of what we
perceive and there were basically three
schools of thought that we in this part
in this paper argued were relevant for
ai systems basically that there is
vagueness with respect to perception
there is vagueness with respect to the
language we use to talk about
uh the systems that we are building and
the features that they observe and
there's also possibly a vagueness in our
awareness or lack thereof of the reality
that these systems are meant to refer to
the institutional apparatus the social
domains the applications
that they are meant to work on
and the payoff here was we basically
said all of these positions
these references to indeterminacy
actually manifest materially
at distinct stages of ai development so
basically when you when you hear ai
developers talk about the need to
specify a model the need to define the
features over which you are optimizing
uh
the the concern over who should or
should not have access to the api
what you're actually hearing is in a
practical sense a kind of skidding up
against the boundaries of these
different kinds of vagueness
because at different stages of ai
development we often talk about design
training deployment in the paper we sort
of basically elevate those kind of banal
terms into the kind of philosophical
correlates of
what we mean by ai systems that
interface with the world
what we call in this paper featurization
optimization and then integration
all of which feed into
uh this term we introduced what we call
sociotechnical specification the problem
of defining the relationship
between the system and social reality
and so i'll just briefly for the
remainder of this talk go into a bit
more detail on each of these
these dimensions uh how this
indeterminacy can manifest this is a
very i know smith knows this very well
it's a very famous video um that ai
safety researchers love um of a game uh
computer game in which place here
i think it's called wave runner you
basically have a boat that they've
trained as reinforcement learning that
they used here they they trained an
agent to try to win this race to compete
with the other uh the other boats
and uh they used a proxy uh for
what what this was trying to do
because it's really hard to just sort of
you know train it on win the race so
what they train and always get the most
points they assumed get the most points
meant you're going to win the race as
you can see from the video that's that's
not true uh what the agent has learned
uh is that there's actually this weird
little loopty loop that it could do
uh because there's like two bro boosters
or whatever like that so you can
basically get infinite points
if it learns to not win the race to just
sort of like play its own game so to
speak
what's interesting about this is that
the agent is doing exactly what was told
the agent is not confused the agent is
not stupid the agent is actually smarter
as specified
uh than any human who would play this
game because what it was told to do it's
found the perfect way to do which is get
the most points um and so this problem
of featurization became kind of my way
of referencing this problem of exactly
what are the features of the domain of
the environment
that should matter most
to what is being learned and if you
misspecify that it's going to learn
something that's not so much wrong as
reinterpreting the world in which it's
operating
and so when you hear people talk about
existential risk due to ai when you hear
them talk about the paperclip problem
the problem of defining rewards this is
basically what you're referring to is
that the system is going to end up in a
a recourse where it perverts or contorts
the world
for the sake of what it was told to do i
should add that like marx himself in the
manifesto gave an example of this when
he talks about um basically like he's
drawing on the metaphor of the
sorcerer's apprentice because basically
you're you're teaching the broom so to
speak just like sort of give you
infinite water and marx transposed that
onto the relationship between uh thank
you uh the bourgeoisie and the
proletariat that the proletariat will
naturally kind of rise up and
destroy their masters because they were
told to do the wrong thing
but that's maybe a a different topic um
moving ahead here so basically this is
just to say like accidents will happen
in any domain self-driving cars or
otherwise
when there's some mismatch between the
features that actually matter and those
assumed by the engineer model as the
designer specified them
i'll move ahead here since i'm limited
on time but basically optimization
a little bit more of an abstract problem
than featurization where you're the
problem here is like how is it you're
managing the feedback between the system
and the environment over time so in the
case of like i and actually my read my
subscript research speaks to this
self-driving cars or uber or lyft
ride-sharing fleets
uh basically can perform optimally but
destroy roads at the same time because
of road wear or because they gentrify
cities or because
they induce changes in the preference
distribution of what their consumer
model is of people you can't take the
world for granted when you make these
systems work well
and another form that can take and you
know
online like radicalization with social
media is another politically speaking
um but that the world is material the
world is physical and it will wear down
the better you make these systems
because you're you're doubling down on
features that are convenient for
optimization but otherwise uh you you um
those things need to be sustained in
their own right regardless of whatever
the system has been told to do so this
is a different kind of damage that
happens when there's a when these
sources of feedback are ignored or
mismatched
uh over time sequentially uh generating
unstable conditions for performance
and then finally just to give a brief
example here there's actually most
illustrated best through apis but we
just sort of call it the problem of
integration which is basically this
problem where again with reference to
self-driving cars for example you can
make these systems very safe you can
make them drive accurately you can help
them understand stop signs you can help
them negotiate four-way stops perfectly
but you're still privatizing roads
if you're waymo or your cruise or you're
some other company that's working with
these modules and so this problem of
like well where where exactly is the
publicness of the domain
roads are public they're they're
basically meant to be used however the
public chooses to use them so to
optimize them even in a sustainable way
could still contort them because you're
basically putting yourself in the
position of exercising discretion
over what can or cannot be done with
roads so obviously roads are multimodal
there's this unanswered question of how
pedestrians cyclists other human drivers
other modes of transport are meant to be
sharing the roads with these systems
given that the systems were building avs
automated vehicles might be more optimal
than other forms of transit and that's a
way in which the politics can be
contorted so in the case again of
self-driving cars one of the most common
cases for my phd thesis
um there's this question of like how it
is you're integrating a system in
relationship with infrastructure that
you're not meant to control you're not
in a you're not meant to be in a
position to have that kind of discretion
towards
and again there's an indeterminacy here
about well what is the public interest
once you're building a system that can
squeeze so much more utility out of
infrastructure that was never meant to
be used that way
so just in closing i'll say
what what the result of this of this
framework was that me and my
collaborators were building was the idea
that designers ai designers are really
only in a position
uh to roughly fix the parameters of
system performance when they bear on
these different forms of indeterminacy
precisifying can only get you so far
in ways that that are beyond your
control and really i'll just say you
know as my final word that like this is
really all rooted in this problem that
most ai systems today we still have a
relationship with them that historically
is analogous to like what alchemy was in
you know the 15th 16th 17th centuries
basically where you're in a closet
you're doing your own like fudging with
like whatever this experiment is but
there's no ability to
for the public or any kind of external
actor to weigh in and provide feedback
on whether or not the alchemist is
making accurate decisions about uh the
chemicals you're manipulating in other
words like ai is not scientific
predominantly
and then i think actually to design ai
in the interest of humanity will mean
making it into a more scientific
endeavor where these indeterminacies can
be investigated by
a more diverse group of stakeholders so
i'll end there thank you very much